en los supermercados los envases del
salmón escocés muestran aguas prístinas
y proyectan una imagen de producto
limpio y natural pero el salmón salvaje
ya no se pesca comercialmente en ningún
lugar del reino unido- en realidad se
crían cientos de miles de peces a la vez
en corrales suspendidos en mar abierto
como este los salmones nadan dentro de
los corrales hasta dos años las
condiciones han sido denunciadas por
organizaciones ecologistas que
consiguieron infiltrarse en las
piscifactorías para filmar estas
imágenes
muchos de los salmones son comidos vivos
por los piojos de mar
otros tienen la piel desprendida o les
faltan trozos de carne
según este especialista en medio
ambiente el hacinamiento hace que el 25
por ciento de los salmones de la
piscifactoría mueran antes de llegar a
la edad adulta
y
estas imágenes se grabaron a finales de
2020 y nuestras almas muy enfermos es un
entorno perfecto para que se desarrollen
los parásitos pueden multiplicarse
exponencialmente
si esa misma tasa de mortalidad se diera
en los pollos de granja los cerdos de
granja el ganado vacuno o las ovejas de
granja habría un clamor público
se teme que los parásitos se estén
extendiendo más allá de las
piscifactorías los salmones salvajes que
pasan por este río también podrían
contaminarse al migrar hacia el mar
hay unas 150 piscifactorías muy cerca de
las desembocaduras de los ríos
así que los peces tienen que pasar cerca
de estas piscifactorías no hay forma de
evitarlas
estas acusaciones de infección
generalizada se han repetido en informes
parlamentarios pero la industria
escocesa del salmón las ha rechazado
diciendo que carecen de pruebas las
explotaciones más grandes se negaron a
ser grabadas la única empresa que aceptó
recibirnos es mucho más pequeña aunque
sigue creando una cantidad impresionante
de peces en el corral tiene 15 metros
por 15 metros y 10 metros de profundidad
y dentro de eso hay 4500 peces
esta es una de las piscifactorías con
buenas prácticas prueba de que la
piscicultura puede ser más respetuosa
con el medio ambiente los salmones están
protegidos de forma natural por los
llamados peces y limpiadores que se
alimentan de los piojos evitando la
necesidad de utilizar productos químicos
pero para que esta solución funcione la
piscifactoría tuvo que limitar la
densidad de sus corrales e invertir en
la innovadora técnica es una solución
que podrían utilizar todas las
explotaciones
posiblemente pero algunas piscifactorías
son realmente grandes por lo que
necesitarían una gran cantidad de peces
para poner los corales
estamos trabajando aquí en pequeños
corrales lo que es probablemente una
buena idea
por ello las organizaciones ecologistas
quieren reducir el tamaño de las
explotaciones lo antes posible a pesar
de los beneficios económicos las
capturas de salmón salvajes están en su
nivel más bajo desde que se tienen
registros
el declive no solo se achaca a los
parásitos sino también al cambio
climático
la captura de salmones en el río space
es ahora aproximadamente la mitad de lo
que era en su apogeo a finales de los
años 70
este grupo de pescadores y científicos
ha estado capturando salmones jóvenes
poniéndoles microchip y devolviendo los
al río con la esperanza de comprender
mejor cómo el salmón se ve afectado por
los fenómenos climáticos
en este momento estamos viendo caudales
más extremos lluvias más extremas por lo
que el río sube muy rápido con más
frecuencia y eso puede ser bastante
perjudicial para la ecología del salmón
lavar los huevos de la grava por ejemplo
así que tenemos menos peces juveniles
escocía enfrenta un doble desafío
proteger a los salmones en los ríos y
mejorar la regulación de la crianza en
las piscifactorías al mismo tiempo la
producción no para de aumentar
doscientas tres mil toneladas en 2019 es
un récord y representa un alza del 30
por ciento respecto al año anterior